the verdict sentencing canadian michael
spavil to 11 years in prison was
delivered behind closed doors in a
courtroom in the northeastern chinese
city of dan dong
the city had been home to the
businessman who organized tours to north
korea until he was detained in december
2018 and charged with sharing state
secrets
former canadian diplomat michael kovrick
was also arrested and charged with
spying both men were tried in march
after more than two years in detention
spawn's sentence was condemned by
canada's ambassador to china
we've maintained from the beginning
that michael spatter and michael kovrig
are being detained arbitrarily and we
will continue to call for their
immediate release
the announcement came as chinese
executive mong won jo faces court in
vancouver in a final push to fight
extradition to the united states
the former huawei chief financial
officer is accused of violating
sanctions on iran
relations between china and canada have
soured considerably
when joe's case is purely politically
motivated these two canadians are
suspected of endangering china's state
security
spava and kovig were detained just weeks
after mung's arrest
ottawa has accused beijing of hostage
diplomacy
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
issued a statement saying the ruling was
unjust and lacked transparency
representatives from 25 countries
including the us uk and japan appeared
at the canadian embassy in beijing in
support of spabo the chinese court
sentenced michael svavo to 11 years in
prison and ordered his deportation but
it's unclear when that would happen
canadian officials say it's most likely
after the jail term is served but some
analysts say it could be sooner an
option used as a bargaining chip with
canada it all hangs on what happens to
miss mung in vancouver and perhaps later
if she is extradited in washington
the verdict follows the upholding of the
death sentence of another canadian
robert schellenberg on tuesday he was
jailed in china in 2014 for drug
smuggling it's unclear when the court
will give its decision on michael
kovrick michael spavy has 10 days to
appeal his sentence but in a country
where 99 percent of criminal cases are
found guilty the chances of overturning
the ruling are unlikely
katrina you al jazeera beijing